I don't even know where we left off you
were still in a relationship I was yep
damn
things change really quickly you okay
not okay
I'm really good at being calm when
there's turbulence
but this has been a whirlwind of a year
today
yeah I don't know
everything with her ex-husband I don't
think you realize the weight of the
world is on your shoulders he has made
it the most insane narrative we stay
silent through all the lies from my kids
mom just told me that it was melanoma
this on her face is very concerning I
don't think I've seen you this slow she
doesn't sleep she's lost a lot of weight
melanoma is deadly this was way more
serious than I anticipated it to be
have you talked to court about Milan my
sister used my wedding as a business
opportunity she's mad at me live it
she felt like her wedding Vibes were
like stripped from her I'm really
confused how this narrative came into
her head like I couldn't have been more
mindful I said don't do anything that
Courtney wore to her wedding I see both
sides yeah I see both sides people think
that's a misunderstanding it's not
it's who she is to her core
we want to make God laugh tell them your
plans all of us just need to have a
bigger conversation about the beauty
standards that we're setting
I don't want my daughter to do the
things I did I wish I'd never touched
anything to begin with
how's everything going with Tristan
where are you guys stand I think he
thinks and let's just ride this out but
no no chances we know how to have fun
together
know how to be there for each other
but only the superficial level what
this tension goes way back
family is what I value the most so I
just feel very anxious I just don't
think everything's gonna be okay
[Music]